but I really want to highlight it's
every single person you can always think
about maybe five people who've had a
deep influence on the trajectory of your
career or your life and you've got to
make those decisions who are those
people when you meet them it mightn't be
obvious but they make that change from
going from a big corporate role into a a
startup and I think anyone who's been in
the startup knows when you go to sleep
at night everything stops and it starts
when you wake up in the morning and get
going again that's the way I would sort
of describe is what inspires you and how
does it work you're inspired you take
the leap obviously not stupidly you burn
the boats and burn the bridges and you
have to employ all of your passion and
all of your brains to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
it John rart welcome to 20 minute
leaders and the Maas experiment I'm so
excited to be experimenting with you
over the next and over the next while
and into your world which is pretty
different than the worlds I'm usually in
so this is why I do the show and I'm and
I'm so I'm so excited for that so John
thank you for joining me today thank you
very much Michael it's good to uh good
to be with you and looking forward to
our talk all right so John diving right
in and tell me a little bit about your
world you know how do you how would you
describe it in your own words so my
world as an entrepreneur and as a
co-founder and CEO on the co-founder and
CEO of a company called lit thinking
it's an interesting name and it has a
lot to do with being smart and having
something to do with life the life
Spectrum um what we do is we we we we
believe we're going to change the world
believe it or not and what we
specifically focus on uh are aerosolized
pathogens uh big uh big terminology
basically viruses bacteria spores and uh
and what uh what the uh easiest way to
describe it is the common coal
tuberculosis Co influenza and a lot of
Hospital quiet infections all of those
um are principally the principal way you
catch them is through Eros aerosolized
pathogens you breathe in and you get an
infection so imagine somebody sneezing
in your face that uh that is a lot of
how you catch colds uh what we do is we
use human safe uh uh invisible light in
the far ultraviolet Spectrum which is
very very safe for people and very very
effective against pathogens and this is
uh something which has been known about
for a long time in general but the way
to apply it is only recently understood
the ability to actually be exposed to
the light not harmed and have a very
very very effective way of reducing your
risk of infection and we think that uh
this is the right thing to do for the
world it's the right thing to do for
Science and again the trajectory of this
is going to be a mega Trend and it's
going to change change the way we live
so so John can you can you walk me
through still a little bit more what
what's changed in in the world and
what's un what has been unlocked that is
now enabling us to to do what you're
doing at stale good question Michael um
so if you think about like what's been
very very well known for over 100 years
this is ultraviolet light in effect
kills germs um it it inactivates viruses
and the way it does that is it damages
them they're simple very very simple
cell uh uh uh uh uh uh entities and if
you can damage them to a point where
they can't replicate you've effectively
killed them um same story with uh with
bacteria and what we do is we use
ultraviolet light to do that now the
problem uh that been long known is while
it's very effective against germs what
it does do is Burns you and everyone
knows that whoever's had sunber is uh
has experienced that firsthand and
there's always been this view of oh my
goodness ultraviolet light it's great
but you know you can't get too close to
it it's as simple as that um in the in
the 2010s a really incredible uh uh
scientist called The Professor David
brener from Columbia University he uh he
uh along with others but uh he
principally spearheaded this idea that
is there a a frequency in the UV
Spectrum which is effective against
germs but doesn't harm people and what
we found is that there's this space
called it's called far UVC um
ultraviolet C Spectrum it's right at the
end of it 200 to 230 nanometers and just
for reference 400 to 700 is the visible
spectrum and then you go into the
ultraviolet Spectrum then you go
microwaves so so um this specific
wavelength what we found is that it
doesn't penetrate the skin it doesn't
get through that dead skin dead skin
layer those very very very top layers
that don't have a problem because
they're dead skin already and a similar
story with the eyes so here we have this
amazing amazing amazing amazing
discovery which is I can kill germs I
can I can I can effectively inactivate
pathogens without Haring people without
harming animals and since around 2014
through to now there's been a lot of
research which has been accelerated by
Co that continues to build the evidence
that it's very very safe uh in in
effective doses for humans and it's very
effective against uh against germs so
that's where we see a big change
because you know if you think about our
ancestors you know 200 years ago it was
pretty pretty obvious that you know five
children born into a family a couple of
them would die of illness and it was
something that everyone would just
simply well this is the way of life it's
a very hard life you know people die
early they die young and today it's in
the first world certainly it's something
that is is a horrifying Prospect because
we've had antibiotics we've had all of
those things well today we're living in
an environment where it's fine to spend
a week a year on your back in bed or at
home with a horrible cold or the flu or
God forbid something more serious and
the world has millions of people who die
of Hospital acquired infections but
other things like tuberculosis and even
the common the common flu uh uh claims
over a million lives uh annually
globally so these are real issues that
we kind of have that mindset which is oh
well you know it's just a cold it's just
the flu the productivity burden is huge
so we think that this is something which
is obviously for the day-to-day work uh
uh uh uh there's a market there a latent
Market just for for normal living but
what about for the pandemics and I can
talk to you about that as well okay this
is I mean this is really interesting I
me you're really taking it I and I love
the I love the going back to the analogy
of what the way we've treated different
different I guess just accepted
situations in our life and now they we
we we can we don't necessarily have to
conform to those same standards but we
can level up and in in in very
fundamental areas of of how we live our
life like what you're mentioning um yeah
with with the cold and I was also really
curious from a product perspective what
you said about the fact that the big Ena
one of the big enablers here is this new
wavelength right this new that this that
that doesn't burn the skin that is why
you can now exercise this safely how
much explaining does this require to get
people who before considered this to be
harmful to now accept it as not how do
you do that
transition um it it feels difficult it
ain't easy um and I think for the people
who are listening in this particularly
if you've got Founders and entrepreneurs
who are right at the beginning of an
adop an adoption curve it's one thing to
join a market where there is an existing
solution but it's another thing to say I
I have a solution to a problem that's
not well articulated nobody wants to
talk about Co anymore everyone wants to
forget about it you know you go out and
you burn your masks in a sacrificial
bonfire in your yard you know because
nobody really wants to talk about it um
but the reality is that um um you've got
uh
well let me let me say one other thing
prevention is hard to sell it's a lot
easier to sell a cure than it is to sell
prevention so we're right at the
beginning of this market and what we
know uh is that it's hard to get people
to do something where they don't have an
apparent problem your biggest competitor
as they say is doing nothing um I think
a lot of people you know when you think
about the psychology I'm always going to
go on a diet tomorrow I'm always going
to start my exercise regime next week
not today and it's that trying to get
that across the line so that adoption of
new innovation curve color TV cellular
phones tablets air conditioning
microwave OV as you name it all have
their own story washing machines
electricity the radio everything has its
own story but in general things are
speeding up and what we know is that uh
there are a couple of things that really
change the game and you're looking for
that as an entrepreneur and as a startup
you're looking for what is it that is a
compelling reason now the logic it it
makes a heck of a lot of sense there's
hundreds of millions of lives at risk
when it comes to the next pandemic it
won't be another 100 years obviously
population growth viral mutation
proximity of animals and people it's
guaranteed that there's going to be you
know mathematically there's going to be
another pandemic but people won't buy on
that what they will buy on and what they
will understand is you focus on people
who are early adopters people who really
are fascinated by this and have a a
linkage to a personal story and a
crusade and what we we do is we look for
those early adopters who understand the
technology and want to join us on that
on on that journey and that so far is
starting to work in the healthc care
industry it works even in General
Offices places of worship mass transit
there are always going to be case
studies where you've got a buying the
decision that's made that's influenced
by something which is just a little bit
out of the ordinary so you're looking
for those imperfections and those early
adopters and what some what we also do
is look at well what else can fuv do and
our device is very clever it's connected
it works it's certified it's uh it's
very very effective and it exists uh
here in the US it's UL approved it's EPA
approved and and we we we we've made
sure that we're very very compliant so
you answer those first two questions
does it work we have plenty of
independent studies to show what works
and a lot of scientific data and then uh
is it safe and again over a hundred
studies internationally recognized
studies peer reviews show that it's safe
along with um regulatory approval so you
you have to start with that does it work
is it safe and then the discussion can
commence and then you look for other
imperfections that you're trying to for
solve what other problems well far you V
also is very effective against mold
that's a dirty little secret in a lot of
buildings mold um it's also helps with
Energy Efficiency simply because the uh
in the US the CDC has recommended a
minimum of five air changes per hour
most buildings don't do five air changes
per hour what we're able to do is use a
technique that purifies the air that
gives you the equivalent of up to 100
plus air changes an hour so you think
about well I don't want to upgrade my
air conditioning because that's going to
cost a lot it's going to spend a lot of
energy what we're able to do is provide
a solution Which is far more coste
effective 14 watts per device goes into
the ceiling it's very very coste
effective and it's silent and it's
continuous and it works so you're
looking for the solution set that's
going to solve a problem even if that
problem is unstated at the moment wow so
I mean all of that sounds for you know
for you as an entrepreneur it adds it
adds pretty interesting challenges
Beyond just the product development the
traditional challenges of of selling and
everything in between right I mean it's
a you're adding on really rethinking and
reshaping a market and um and
perceptions yeah which I think is quite
quite an interesting Endeavor to to take
on what has led you here to to this
journey great story um um you know
everyone's got their own story and if
you think about your life you know
there's these what I would call you know
almost polls these these points that
change the trajectory of your career or
the trajectory of your life and and for
me I'm a 30-year veteran of Honeywell
International um I uh and before that um
you know I'm I'm an electrical engineer
I uh I I ended up joining the British
Merchant Navy for a couple of years and
that changed my life you know I'm
Australian I was a a boy who was born in
Sydney and I ended up in effect running
way to see and joining the Navy and
becoming an electrical officer on a
cruise ship I traveled the world and it
opened my eyes but there was that point
that uh I I I I uh I worked with a guy
who'd done it and who influenced me and
he he said why don't you call and why
don't you apply and I did it and it
changed the trajectory of my life I I
came back uh to Australia after a couple
of years as an international citizen I
worked in this great company and
and it was about having people who are
influencers who say have you ever
thought they open your eyes up and you
you start expanding sort of the
possibilities for your life so many of
us constrict ourselves anyway to cut a
long story short a really successful 30
years I ended up uh as the global
president of uh honeyball Building
Solutions a large multi-billion Dollar
business unit again leveraging that
Global Experience L leveraging
engineering and a real passion for
saving energy and making buildings more
effective and then an opportunity came
up uh and this opportunity again the
sort of cuts of the chase uh one of the
world's greatest uh property developers
Steven Ross uh who's the founder and
chairman of the related companies here
in the US um and a guy called Matt
Higgins who is the co-founder and CEO of
RSC Ventures the venture capital L uh I
I I met with them and they they they
they they basically said we think that
this technology this science makes sense
and we sat down and we agreed and it was
a big risk for me and obviously they
were they they had a lot of faith that
we would start up a company and they
they provided the uh the funds to start
up this company and develop an offering
and launch and that that was two years
ago and you it's about taking risk but I
really want to highlight it's every
single person you can always think maybe
five people who've had a deep influence
on the trajectory of your career or your
life and you've got to make those
decisions who are those people when you
meet them it might be obvious but they
they they they make that change and from
going from a big corporate role into a
uh a startup and I think anyone who's
been in the startup knows when you go to
sleep at night uh everything stops and
it starts when you wake up in the
morning and get going again it the
Machinery doesn't doesn't keep happening
you've got to make it work you're
employee number one you drag yourself
out of the swamp you dry yourself off
you wear any clothes that will fit you
you go out and figure out you'll eat
anything you'll do anything to get going
to take the next step and then it gets
easier as it goes along but it takes a
lot a lot of courage and a lot of uh you
know a lot of adrenaline but it's really
those that's the way I would sort of
describe it is what inspires you and how
does it work you're inspired you take
the leap obviously not stupidly you burn
the boats and burn the bridges and uh
and and and and and you have to employ
all of your passion and all of your
brains to do it John I I love it and
that was a and that was quite a quite
sounds like quite a journey and and a
very very cool one coupled with a lot of
inspiration and curiosity and excitement
and um and and U great Circ
circumstances that have that have
brought you to to this moment so so John
I really want to thank you for joining
me and sharing with me this journey and
your insights wishing you best of luck
sharing from the side very excited for a
world in which I'm not going to get a
cold in the office like I I usually do
um and and the many more benefits of
what you're doing and and so thank you
very much for everything great well lit
lit thinking.com just as it's spelled
lit thinking.com great to uh great to uh
meet you Michael and great to talk to
you and wish you and your listeners the
best thank you thank you so much